welcome to this meeting of the council
i will now ask reverend richard isles to
lead us in prayers
and he will also then lead us in a
minute silence
to councillor craig canel whose funeral
took place yesterday
thank you
perhaps the words from
the old testament book of ecclesiastes
are worthy of being read this evening
they speak of things that happen in life
and as this council meets to discuss the
issues for the local residents and the
local community these words may be worth
listening to once more
teacher
for everything that happens in life
there is a season
a right season for everything
under heaven
a time to be born and a time to die a
time to plant and a time to collect the
harvest
a time to kill and a time to heal a time
to tear down and a time to build up
a time to cry
and a time to laugh a time to mourn
and a time to dance
a time to scatter stones
a time to pile them up
a time for a warm embrace
a time for keeping your distance
a time to search and a time to give up
as lost
a time to keep and a time to throw out
a time to tear apart
and a time to bind together
a time to be quiet and a time to speak
up a time to love and a time to hate a
time to go to war and a time to make
peace
solomon then said
i turn my attention to the ways of
wisdom folly and madness i asked what is
left for those who come after the king
to do
they can only repeat what he has already
done
i realized
that wisdom
is better than folly just as light is
better than darkness
as the old saying goes
the wise have eyes in their heads
but the fools stumble
in the darkness
let us pray
jesus you were born in a little town
and in this season we will shortly
celebrate your birth
yet you grew up under the authority of
local leaders and officials who managed
the majority of your daily life
we remember and mourn
those who are no longer with us
and yet we lift up our leaders today
we pray for our local councillors
gathered here this evening
and all who serve our local communities
strengthen them with with wisdom and
grace for the heavy burdens they carry
may they manage their teams and pro
and projects with greatness and love
and keep their hearts pure and eyes
turned towards your face we pray as they
work in the interests
of the people they are called
to serve
in jesus name we ask these things
our men amen
members would would you like to take
your seats please
we remember at the outset of this
meeting
the life
of craig
canel
and the millet of silence
thank you
thank you reverend
isles
please take your seats
members
we have delayed paying tribute to
councillor craig cannell
in respect of his family's wish
that we do this after the funeral
service that was held yesterday
i was very honored to attend yesterday's
service in memory of craig in boston
lincolnshire where craig grew up
and found the service
very moving
craig
joined the council in january 2018
aged just 28
representing residents
in the down hall and rora ford
he followed in the footsteps of another
liberal democrat councillor chris black
in the may elections the residents of
raleigh voted craig in for another full
term of office
as their district councillor but in
addition they also chose him to
represent him
as their county councillor
for the rayleigh north division and as
their
raley town councillor
all this
while working full-time for transport
for london
as a product design manager
he was proud to represent raley
residents and loved raley's historic
buildings green spaces
and strong sense of community
he will be very much missed by us all
in advance
of the meeting councillor wootton
and councillor have both contacted me to
say that they would like to pay to
tribute to craig
i will also ask councillor james newport
councillor christine mason councillor
mike wilkinson
if they would like to say something in
tribute to craig
before i do so
if there are any other members who would
like to say something can you please
raise your hand clearly in the air now
so that we can make a note of your names
thank you members
so everyone
councillor button can i invite you to
speak
madam chairman
yesterday it was my privilege and honor
to be able to attend the funeral service
of councillor craig cannell
both in my capacity as leader of rocha
district council and also to personally
pay my respects to a man i really
liked no one could fail to be
emotionally moved by the wonderful and
brave tributes to craig
superbly well delivered made by his
fiance charlotte
as well as craig's mother trish father
alan and his three sisters christina
gemma and lucy
as tends to be the case at funerals we
learned much more about craig the man
than we knew beforehand
and for anyone who was not able to view
the service online yesterday
can i suggest that you take a little
time over the next few days to view the
recording
there is absolutely no way in the few
moments that i have now to adequately
convey what a truly remarkable and loved
man he was
at just 32 years of age taken from us so
young
and with so much talent still to offer
his passing still seemed so unreal and
so difficult for us to rationalize or
come to terms with
my first acquaintance with craig was in
mid-2019 soon after i had been elected
when rather hesitantly he came up to me
at the end of a council meeting in the
civic suite chamber and congratulated me
on the delivery of my maiden speech
since then we have had numerous
conversations invariably about issues to
do with council matters in order that he
could familiarize himself with the
detail of an issue
and so that he could vote with a clear
understanding and confidence in what he
believed with the best interests of the
residents he
represented on the morning of the 2nd of
november we had one of those
conversations on an agenda item for the
council meeting that day
also later the same day after the
various tributes to sir david amis
he came up to the deputy leader
councillor cheryl rowe and myself and
said how much he had enjoyed listening
to the kind words said about sir david
and added that he felt his own life was
the poorer for not having known sir
david personally
particularly
at such a young age
his caring and compassionate interest to
do good in the community he represented
was inspirational
put simply craig was quite one of the
nicest people i have met in political
circles in watchful district council
he will be hugely missed by all of us
our thoughts and prayers are
particularly with craig's fiance
charlotte his family and friends to whom
we send our sympathy and condolences at
this very sad and difficult time
and with your permission madam chairman
i'm going to probably do a first in this
council
and i'm actually going to make a
proposal please that the balance of
craig's allowance
rounded up to two and a half thousand
pounds
be donated to the craig canel foundation
trust
thank you madam chairman
[Applause]
do i have a second year for that
thank you chairman i'll second that
thank you
members we will need to take this to the
vote
those in favor of what uh councillor
wooten has just proposed to put the uh
the finances to
towards craig's
charity please raise your hand
members that is unanimous
i'm carried
i'll come to that
okay so can i now invite councillor ro
to speak
thank you chairman
i think the leader has said it all
members and guests
but for me personally craig was a
gentleman
with never a bad word to say about
anybody
watching the funeral yesterday i think
charlotte and the rest of the family
summed up craig
a lovely service for a lovely man
taken from us far too young
craig
rest in peace you will be truly missed
thank you councillor can i now invite
councillor james newport
to speak
now
okay
members
the tragic sudden loss of craig
has left many of us stunned shocked and
heartbroken
he was a shining star within our local
party and indeed within the council
he was a worthy counselor who followed
in the giant footsteps of chris black
sharing many
of chris's attributes with his warmth
kindness and generosity
looking back through my whatsapp
messages from craig
i realized just how generous he was
when he told me i was diplomatic
he certainly knew how to keep on
people's good side
craig was especially generous with his
time giving endless hours to the local
community which he had adopted as his
own
after only living in the district for a
relatively short time
craig would work tirelessly to try and
find solutions to local issues
and i remember him calling me one day
to ask me what i thought about a project
he was looking to get involved in
he came to me with the idea of the
banking hub in rochford and i must admit
i told him i had reservations
as it seemed like it would take a huge
amount of time and i knew how busy he
was already with his work
and the council
however
undeterred
craig set about
working away in the background with
others to bring the project to fruition
and to a great reception by the
community of rochford
during the pandemic
he volunteered for the nightingale
hospital and organized food parcels for
local residents
all while still working remotely and
attending many meetings
craig's campaigning and enthusiasm for
politics never appear to wane despite
the frustrations
that are often felt in opposition he
remained determined to win
his determination certainly paid off
when in may 2021 after masterminding a
campaign he scored the hat-trick and was
simultaneously elected to county
district and town council
craig was modest to say the least and i
remember him and i remember telling him
that he should be proud of what he had
achieved
after all
he had made me walk 12 miles in one day
delivering his leaflets
what else can i say apart from we will
miss craig dearly
with all his kind caring
warmth and generosity
and it was a privilege for chris and i
to have stood alongside craig as part of
the lib dem team
we can now only imagine what he would
have achieved in the future
thank you chairman
thank you councillor newport
councillor christine mason
can i invite you to speak please
should i start again that sounds
better perhaps it doesn't
i speak for all of the rochford district
residence team including the many
non-councillors that knew craig
i say
how sad we are at the unexpected death
of craig at such a young age
although craig had been on the council
for a relatively short time in that
period he had demonstrated his
willingness and ability
to deal with many different and often
difficult issues
and earned the respect of those that
like myself
had the privilege of working with him
his enthusiasm
energy and abilities will be greatly
missed
i would like to extend our sympathies to
his fiancee family and friends who have
a difficult path ahead of them and
reassure them that craig's contribution
to the local community will not be
forgotten
thank you councillor mason
councillor wilkinson
thank you chairman
no life
is more important than the other
everybody's life is precious
but every now and then
we are privileged to meet somebody who
stands head and shoulders above the rest
for me the most recent was craig
he has been described this evening as a
shining light i think
whilst i understand the words that
doesn't do him justice and fairness
because
he was the most diplomatic passionate
enthusiastic motivated hard-working
member of this council that i've spoken
to he and i used to speak regularly
whilst we're not
we were never part of the same political
group
we were pretty much totally politically
aligned on everything that we dealt with
and he and i would
bounce ideas off each other regularly
for
for me he is an example
of how we should all conduct ourselves
i think the fact listening to
the the people who have spoken this
evening listening to the tributes from
yourself chairman
and and i'm sure that the the thoughts
are shared by by us all
the respect that we all have for craig
and i use the present tense because we
still have that respect for him
is a testament to his ability to be an
absolute diplomat even though you didn't
may not have always agreed with him you
could never argue with the way in which
he delivered what he wanted to say
and i personally
will use craig's example
um in the future for myself
uh and try and learn from it and i would
encourage all members to do the same
um to finalize chairman i would i'd like
to pass on my
thoughts to the family and particularly
to charlotte who's sitting here
having met them yesterday at the funeral
i can see why craig ended up the person
he is because they are an incredible
family
he has a wonderful sisters
um he has a wonderful fiancee
um albeit she drinks too much as she did
last night
um
and i i
i just would just like to to say that uh
you know
ever so sorry for your loss and um
craig is a wonderful person who will
live in our hearts forever
thank
you thank you councillor wilkinson
councillor eves can i invite you to
speak please
like many of us here i think we probably
only knew
one facet of craig
but the one thing that we all
realized is that he was a man of class
he was always very passionate about what
he
was involved in
and the relationships that he had
as i wasn't here
at the meeting where he sadly collapsed
i listened back to the recording
and i was moved
to hear that one of the last things that
craig said
was in defense of me
over some things that were said in that
meeting
his humanity
his professionalism
and service to the community he served
so well
would be greatly missed by all
my thoughts and my prayers are very much
with his fiance charlotte
and his family and friends at this very
difficult time
i'm sure many of us here
will feel exactly the same way
thank you craig for your service
may you rest in peace
thank you councillors
can i invite councillor hoy to speak
please
thank you chairman
um
i think for all of us who went to the um
funeral rick yesterday we know craig a
lot better than we did before
as councillor eve said most of us only
knew one or two facets of his character
and his life
charlotte his fiancee
is probably the only person who do all
of them
sorry this is quite difficult
um
we
clearly have lost him far too early and
he obviously and i use his word with a
good reason led an interesting life
and we've learned much of that over the
last few days
um
i found it easier
than rather than talk about it and
people have spoken
very well today of craig
but i found a poem which i think some of
us know i've heard it's only heard it
before but i've never heard it
in such an appropriate setting because
craig did
fit an awful lot into his
short life
this is called the dash
by linda ellis
i read of a man who stood to speak at
the funeral of a friend
he referred to the dates on the
tombstone from the beginning to the end
he knew he noted that first came the
date of birth and spoke the following
date with tears but he said what
mattered most of all was the dash
between those years
for that dash represents all the time
that they spent alive on earth
and now only those who love them
know what little line that like little
line is worth
for it matters not how much we own the
cars the house the cash
what matters is how we live and love
and how we spend our dash
so think about this long and hard
are there things you'd like to change
for you never know how much time is left
that can still be rearranged
if we could just slow down enough to
consider what's true and real
and always try to understand the way
other people
feel and be less quick to anger and show
appreciation more
and love the people in our lives
like we've never loved before
if we treat each other with respect
and will often wear a smile remember
this special dash might only last a
little while
so when this eulogy is being read with
your lice actions to rehash
would you be proud of the things they
say about how you spent your dash
[Applause]
thank you council ahoy can i invite
councillor macpherson
thank you when craig spoke i listened
i think we all listened
craig's knowledge was way beyond his
years and he contributed so much
from my own experience especially to the
carbon neutral project
but it wasn't just what craig said
but how he said it
craig brought integrity
politeness
kindness and civility to this council
something craig and i chatted about was
the absence of civility at times
perhaps
this is craig's legacy for us
to make our environment more civil
kinder polite
to fellow animal lover cray our council
is a far poorer place without you
my deepest sympathy to charla
and her family
rest in peace craig
[Applause]
thank you councilman mcpherson
and finally
councillor steptoe
yes
thank you chairman
i first met craig when he was first
elected
and i've just become deputy leader
and he'd often come to me and we discuss
various aspects
various projects that he was looking for
and trying to do
he was always very quiet in the way he
spoke
always very true to the point
and we had many discussions
and he'd always come back to me
later
and say thank you very much
it came as council newport has mentioned
he came to me
with at the time i thought was a crazy
project
in my ward in rockford
to create a banking hub
for all the banks to use
it sounded crazy at the time
but it's now there and it's working
and extremely well
if nothing else
that is a memorial to him
i also know that a county council today
some very kind words were said about
craig
and i know he will be missed
both here
for the town council
and also
a county
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you councillor steptoe
i will now invite charlotte to say a few
words
hello
i'm usually behind the scenes um never
put myself in this position craig's
probably laughing right now with the
fact that i'm here at council meeting um
he's always invited me i'm like no i'm
not i'm not going to that not me um but
um i just want to say thank you everyone
for your really really kind words about
craig um it's it's hard to be sad but
i'm so proud you know um the fact that
he is this brilliant man and his legacy
will continue to go on and thank you
councillor woodson for your kind um
whatever you call it thing
um but yeah i just want to say thank you
everyone you know the council work for
craig was
what he did you know tfl was you know
what he got paid to do but this was
where his heart was and he always wanted
to make an impact and to hear the impact
he's had in such a short time is is
phenomenal and i just want to say thank
you to everyone for their kind wishes
um and not we say he'll never be
forgotten in anything that he does and
he's always here with all of us so thank
you very much
[Applause]
thank you charlotte
by the way charlotte being a leg to his
table
is an analogy that we too as a family
have used
so i get it
if you know then you'll understand
god bless craig and charlotte and family
thank you all members for your
contribution
i will now turn to agenda item one
apologies for absence
apologies have been received from
councillor mike carter
councillor dre council alumni
councillor merrick councillor milne
councillor pavlin and councillor weston
and council oh hold on a moment
councilor michael hi
thank you
agenda item 2 declarations of interest
councillor hi
thank you
are there any other declarations of
interest members
before we continue with the main
business of the meeting i would like to
move a motion without notice in line
with council procedure rule 14 c
to take items 15 7 11
12 and 13 next and then return to the
main remaining items on the agenda in
order do i have a second place
thank you councillor
can those in favor please raise their
hands right up and keep them up while
officers count them
thank you members please lower your hand
those against
please raise your hands
those abstaining
you was abstaining was you council
reeves
yes thank you
thank
you yes i'll do the numbers first
20
okay
first of all let's finish this item is
421
against zero and abstaining eight
the reason we are moving to these these
items is because we
we need to do the first item
on the agenda which is item 15 and we
can exclude the
public and press and get this item done
first
yes i will read the numbers
yep sorry okay the items were 15
7
11
12
and 13.
i've got
members that motion was carried
i will now move recommendation
that under section 100 a 4 of the local
government act 1972 the public be
excluded from the meeting for the
following items of business on the
grounds that it involves that likely
disclosure of exempt information as
defined in paragraph three of part one
of schedule 12a of the act do i have a
second girl have you just getting that
jim
thank you councillor steptoe
can those in favor please raise your
hands and do not lower them until i ask
you to do so
thank you members those against
any abstentions
thank you members
we have 23 for
none against and three absentions
members of the public
can i please ask
you all to make your way outside the
hall and wait in the canteen area
are they good okay that's good
agenda item 7 to consider any reports
from the executive and committees to
council
7.1 report of the executive advice
services contract for 2022-2024
councillor williams
would you introduce the report please
uh
thank you chairman
members before you is a reporter the
executive
this item was referred to council on the
6th of december yesterday
2021
by the executive with a recommendation
on the advice contract
2022-24
it is proposed that council resolves
that that the contents of the advice
service contract be endorsed as per the
proposal proposals set out on this
report
recommendations are as follows
to agree that the advice service
contract should be retended for a
further two years period
with the option for the council to
extend the extend the contract for a
further one year
it is also proposed that the value of
the contract would continue to be
seventy thousand pounds per year
to recommend that this report be
presented to full council today
seventh of december 2021 to endorse the
proposals therein
should members have any relevant
questions either myself or assistant
director elizabos i'm sure would be
happy to answer these thank you thank
you councillor williams do we have a
seconder for that please
counsellor fd
thank you
would anyone like to speak on this
okay we'll go to the vote then those in
favor
unanimous thank you very much members
that motion is carried
item five seven
two report of the review committee
2122 mid-year treasury management review
councillor wilson chairman of the review
committee will introduce the report
thank you madam chairman
the report is an item of business that
was referred by the review committee on
the 30th of november 2021 to full
council with a recommendation on the
2021-22 mid-year treasury management
review report
at paragraph 1.2 the various bullet
points relate to questions and
observations that were made
by members of the committee
but the one bullet point that i would
like to draw to attention
of members is the final one which is
about the training that is offered
annually by the council and i would
encourage members if they can
to attend that training
thank you councillor wilson
members the recommendation is to note
the contents of the report is that noted
members
thank you
agenda item 11 allocation of seats on
committees
members angela law assistant director
legal and democratic will introduce the
report
thank you chairman
members the purpose of this report is to
agree the allocations of seats to
committees following change in the
political composition
the council has a statutory duty by
virtue of the local government and
housing act 1989 to ensure that
appointments to committees reflect the
proportion of the total number of seats
on the council held by each political
group unless otherwise agreed
following a recent change political
composition has re has been recalculated
um the and the allocation of seats in
accordance with the act
the new committee composition is set out
in appendix one and the nominations to
the new um is set out in the addendum
um in your papers members
chairman the recommendat the
recommendations are set out under
paragraph six on page 11.2
taking recommendation one first chairman
the council resolves that the council's
committee be constituted i set out an
appendix one to this report if you could
please take this to a vote
thank you
members
those that are for this recommendation
please vote
what are we voting on
to consider
the council's committees be constituted
okay let the council committee be
constituted and set out in appendix one
to this report
okay
thank you members you may know your hand
members those are against
and any abstentions
members there is 24 4
none against and for abstentions that is
carried
thank you chairman
in relation to recommendation number two
that members be appointed to serve on
committees for the remainder of the
2021-22 municipal year
chairman nominations have been received
in the office for the chief officer
appointments committee the standards
committee and the statutory officer
personnel committee
the nominations for the rest of the
committees are set out in the addendum
chairman i shall first deal with the
chief officer appointments committee
the conservatives can nominate up to uh
can nominate six seats and the rocha
district residents can nominate to one
seat
in addition between them they can each
nominate to the one remaining seat
we have received seven nominations from
the conservatives and two from the rocha
district residents
council needs to vote to appoint either
councillor eaves councillor myers or
council lisa newport to the two seats
chairman i should take each of the votes
in turn
please can i take the votes for
councillor eves
there are two seats
each it's taken as
separate votes so we will be taking
separate votes for each seat
yes
voting for councillor eves please
for councillor myers
the counsellor lisa newport
15
chairman the votes are councillor eaves
nine votes councillor myers 19 votes
councillor lisa newport nine votes
councillor myers will be allocated one
seat
councillor mrs mason you have two
members with this equal amount of votes
you can either advice officers
whether which of your group members you
wish to allocate a seat or you wish you
may wish to nominate now
thank you firstly i'd like to protest
about the way that this is conducted the
fact that we have two seats
and you give people three votes is
illogical is it at the best
and creates confusion
um
i think in this case though
to be pragmatic
i would nominate councillor eaves to
this seat and councillor lisa the
newport to the statutory offices
personnel committee thank you
thank you council mr mason
chairman for
purposes of currency clarity the chief
officer appointments committee will
consist of councillor robin dre
councillor david merrick councillor gary
myers councillor mrs cheryl rowe council
councillor mrs lawrence
councillor
council whitton councillor eaves and
councillor stanley
so
chairman for the standards committee the
liberal democrats and the independent
group can each nominate to one available
seat
we have received two nominations
one from one from each group can i and
that is counselor stanley or councillor
wilkinson
can i please take the votes for
councillor stanley
thank you
can i ask for a point of clarification
do we now have two votes because there's
two seats
you've you can vote either for
councillor stanley or council wilkinson
there's one seat
okay thank you
if on the previous vote we had three
votes why don't we have two votes this
time
it doesn't make any sense to me
that there is one seat for two
candidates
party to work
can i take the votes for councillor
stanley please
councillor wilkinson
council wilkinson takes the seat on the
standards committee
for clarity
the standards committee will of
councillor dre councillor fd councillor
james gooding councillor lumley
councilman macpherson
councillor
mrs carter
and councillor stanley
oh sorry council mr wilkinson sorry
councillor wilkinson
oh and councilor myers apologies i
thought i had read him out
21 for councillor mr wilkinson and five
for councillor stanley
chairman um
for the
statute officer personnel committee
councillor mrs mason has
early on stated that she will nominate
councillor
lisa newport to the seat
and there are no other nominations to
that seat
chairman the statutory officer personnel
committee will consist of councillor dre
councillor gadsden councillor lumley
councillor merrick councillor rowe
councillor
wooden
council mrs carter council lawman and
councillor lisa newport
thank you chairman
thank you members we will now move on to
agend item 7 agenda item 12 sorry
council of representation on the asset
delivery program partnership panel
members angela law assistant director
and legal democratic will introduce the
report
chairman the purpose of this report is
to appoint seven elected members to the
partnership panel for the remainder of
the
2021-22 municipal year following a
change in the composition of the council
chairman is proposed to appoint the
seven members to the partnership panel
as per
the addendum to it item 12 on page 12.4
thank you
agenda item 13 arrangements to appoint
external auditors from 2023 to 2024.
naomi lucas assistant director resources
will introduce the report chairman sorry
you need to vote
my apologies skipping off
so um
okay
the the addendum that was just read out
so
for councillor dre fd lumley sperrin
steptoe eaves and lawmen those four
please raise your hand
please lower your hands those against
are there any abstentions members
thank you members 24 4
6
sorry zero against and three abstentions
that that is agreed members
agenda item 13 arrangements to
appointment for auditors for 2023-2024
naomi lucas will invite you to
introduce the report please
thank you chair
um yeah as the report sets out the um
we're seeking tonight council's
agreement to opt into the appointing
persons arrangement made by the public
sector audit appointments
for the council's external auditor
appointment for the accounting periods
20 23 24 to 20 27 28
as recommended by audit committee on the
28th of september 2021
just for members information the council
is currently opted into the um
psaa arrangements um for the current
accounting periods up to the end of
2022-23
and under that arrangement
are external auditors that were
allocated under that methodology were um
ey llp who are our current auditors
um it's the council council's duty to
formally respond to the opt-in
invitation by the 11th of march um in
readiness for the 2023-24 financial year
if it does if it chooses not to opt into
this arrangement it must appoint its own
auditor um by the end of next year the
31st of december 2022.
so as i mentioned the decision must
actually be taken by full council as set
out in the local audit accountability
act 2014
um
so there's um three recommend sorry
three options that were considered by
audit committee um on the 28th of
september
and they have agreed to recommend to you
that
the preferred option is to opt in as i
say to the proposed central arrangements
under their public sector auditor
appointments
so that that recommendation needs to be
voted on tonight thank you
thank you
members there's one recommendation set
out in paragraph 8.1 of the report
that the council opts into the proposed
central arrangement for appointing
external auditors for the accounting
period 20 23 24 to 20 27 28
i will move the recommendation do i have
a seconder
thank you councillor
can those in favor please raise your
hands
councillor high
so i was indicating it before the motion
but i wasn't going to change the motion
um
speaking to the motion then the
recommendation by the audit committee
was made
prior to the latest announcement that
the audit was delayed yet again
there's consistently a problem with
later accounts
using this method
or it might it might be other reasons i
i'm just wondering if
if we can have an opinion from naomi on
whether
the extra cost of potentially appointing
our own auditors
may enable us to have a better handle on
the time scale of when the audit is
agreed because consistently the audit
appears errol appears to be late there
is anecdotal evidence that some
auditors
perform their audits quicker than others
um
i think other members may have heard
this but i think
we do not get a good service
from the opt-in
but i'm not sure what
what other options we have and i just
wondered how much the additional cost
would be to appoint our own auditors and
whether it's worth the extra control we
may have on them thank you
thank you councillor hoy
know me are you able to answer all and
yeah thank you chair
um
so there's a limited kind of pool of
available um auditors um in the market
um and all of those um audit firms are
basically experiencing resourcing issues
for a number of
reasons so this is a common um
issue across across the board i'm not
sure the issue at stake here is
necessarily um
whether um
psia
are actually the sort of
cause of these
delays in my opinion
um
that that isn't the root cause of the um
delays experienced
by by audit firms um
so i'm not sure that choosing to opt out
would actually address that issue
directly because if the council was to
appoint its own auditors it would still
be from that existing pool of available
firms and there's
no guarantee that they would be able to
deliver any quick more quickly than is
the case under the current um
arrangements
um
in terms of the um the price um
it's we can't quantify um that what any
additional cost pressure might be as a
result of appointing ourselves or we can
sort of say is that obviously through
economies of scale um it's likely that
we would achieve a better deal um
through appointing um as part of a wider
consortium than we would
individually and i i don't think it is
the case across essex certainly that
those there's only um a couple um of um
public sector organizations the foreign
police
have uh
appointed their own auditors and i don't
think those audits have been completed
significantly um more quickly than um
than those who have had their order
disappointed through ps
aaa
i'd just like to just for the record as
well say that um the delays in the
audit um hasn't
um
the count the council has fulfilled its
responsibilities to publish its accounts
by the due date and to make the relevant
notices on the website about the audit
of the account so the council itself has
met its statutory responsibilities but
um as um council has indicated obviously
there has been some issues across the
board in terms of the audit work being
completed but
we are hopeful that the audit will be
signed off before christmas
thank you
councillor
butcher would you like to come in
thank you
[Music]
can you hear me now yes
thank you chairman
um
yes forgot what i was going to say now
um i agree mainly with uh
with what
naomi lucas has said
there have been some delays with this uh
audit but
i can just assure everybody that
the auditors have been
pushed and
challenged about this and as a council
we have done everything that we are
obliged to do
but my understanding is also that there
is a lack of qualified auditors
in the whole of the country
so
to ask us to
appoint auditors i think would be um
a very challenging challenging yo thing
to do and i think to stick with the psaa
is the right way to go
thank you
thank you council butcher
councillor reeves
thank you chair uh just a
point of clarification really um in
section 1.2 the second bullet point down
the new homes bonus
um we're looking for an update in
december 2021 as that could involve with
the amount of new homes that are being
built in the area here quite a
significant sum i wonder if you've got
an update for us on where we are with
that please thank you
lucas
yes sorry um
thank you chad um
counselors i'm not sure if i quite
follow are you referring to the previous
item agenda about the treasury
management where there wasn't reference
to new homes bonus
i don't believe that relates to this
this item of business so
councillor wootton would you like to
speak next
madam chairman uh thank you very much
indeed look um as a centrally procured
service
the um
winners of the procurement process ought
to be absolutely ideal and it ought to
be an absolute no-brainer uh that we
take advantage of the organization that
is appointed and so the fact that we're
needing to have this discussion
and i understand exactly where council
ahoy is coming from
i think we should be putting pressure on
those that go through the procurement
service to say that frankly it is
falling short we can make all sorts of
excuses we can talk about covid we can
talk about shortage of accountants we
can talk about all sorts of things but i
still believe accountants work in a
competitive environment and i believe
that we should continue to do what you
have already done so excellently through
the audit committee through the section
151 officer and lobby when there is a
failure in terms of service delivery
because that might get the message
through to the procurement
uh providers that uh they need to do a
little better on the service that they
give it's not good enough that we
actually have to work around the
auditors uh and fitting in when it's
convenient when you were ready for the
audit uh many weeks possibly months
before they were ready to do the audit
so i don't think we should just lie down
and accept it thank you very much indeed
madam chairman thank you councilorton
we will now take it to the vote
those in favor please raise your hands
thank you members that was unanimous and
is carried
agenda item three announcements from the
chairman leader
and head of paid services i have a short
announcement
i would like to give a very brief update
from an event held
on sunday during the past weekend by
rochford parish council
it was the festival of light
held in rochford square what a wonderful
time was held by the rochefortians with
lights singers stall sell
selling
homemade gifts and supported by other
services
the market square came alive
and on the contrary to sleepy rochford
it was fun
councillor wootton
thank you madam chairman
you're
on oh you have now
you've turned it off
i don't think so
the light there's an orange light
thank you madam chairman and uh
i'm about to go through a um an update
uh for members uh a similar update will
be given at the
brentwood borough council meeting uh
tomorrow night
but you will recall that at our council
meeting on the 20th of july 2021
approval was given to commence
negotiations with brentwood borough
council on a proposed partnership
arrangement
since that date members of the executive
and i have been working on the
feasibility study that we promised in
order to explore further shared and
partnership opportunities between the
two councils
also reload
resulting from the meeting on the 20th
of july the appointment of jonathan
stevenson as joint ceo
has also been formalized for a period of
six months through a memorandum of
understanding
as part of the feasibility study we've
been working with external experts
shared service architecture
who have supported other counsellors
councils through similar processes
they have helped to facilitate
engagement
ensure alignment and develop a draft
heads of terms for the proposed
partnership
we have had several member sessions
which shared service architecture to
agree red lines
define desired outcomes for the
partnership and to build relationships
with our peers from brentwood borough
council
through these sessions we have created a
shared understanding of what we would
like to achieve together and how this
can be achieved
we have also engaged with senior
leadership teams of both councils to
ensure that they have been included in
the discussions and have been informed
of our thinking
i am pleased to confirm that we have
reached an agreed draft heads of terms
for a formal partnership arrangement
which we will be bringing to an
extraordinary meeting of council in late
january 2022
we had committed to bring back a further
report with proposals by the end of this
year but the timings of meetings and the
considerable work we have been doing has
unfortunately meant this will now slip
to january
in advance of that there will be a
number of sessions led by me
jonathan and the leader of brentwood to
brief all members and all officers about
what these heads of terms mean
we welcome all questions and
constructive challenge as our thinking
will continue to develop as we go
through this process
and to demonstrate our commitment to
that before the extraordinary meeting of
full council we will be bringing back a
report to review committee on the 11th
of january and we welcome the oversight
and scrutiny that committee offers on
our proposed arrangements
i'm very pleased by the progress which
has been made during this feasibility
stage and i would like to thank
colleagues from both brentwood and
rochford for their candor
openness and challenge which has provide
been provided throughout provoking
debate
and giving true blue sky thinking about
how we can transform our respective
councils through innovation and
creativity
i'm very excited by the potential of our
proposed partnership and the
opportunities that it will create
i look forward to speaking to members
about that over the coming weeks thank
you madam chairman thank you
councillorton
agenda item for public questions and
members on notice
members we have no public questions we
do have two members questions on notice
which are set out at item four
council of night
can you please
counsellor michael hoyle would you like
to read out
thank you chairman
will the portfolio holder for it tourism
housing and parking advise on the
current availability of the electric
vehicle charging points in rocha
district provided by or via rdc and
their usage to date
with the portfolio homeowner also
advised on the costs rdc has incurred in
providing these electrical vehicle
charging points and the charges to users
and revenue to date from this provision
thank you council high
councillor fd
thank you chairman
uh i'll tell you's in three parts
because there's basically three
questions there
so the first one is the evaluate the
availability of electric charging points
in which district provided by rdc
all right we have
to my glasses on i'll see you there
um the approach webster's way
and the markets car park railey we have
five fast chargers in total back lane
freight house car parks what should we
have two rapid chargers and one fast
charger
south end road car park cockley we have
one rapid charger
and they're useless usage to date so the
charges have been used a total of
2329 times by 184 different users
consuming over 38 000 kilowatts of
electricity
this equates to
around
112 000 miles saving 22 tons of co2
being released into the atmosphere
and part three is
uh what's cost is the rdc
incurred in these charges the charges
have not cost rdc anything
they have been funded by a government
grant in partnership with the unit
supplier called
suaco
and
suaco continues to maintain the sites at
no cost to the council and no income
profit share is expected until the year
free of the contract which is 22 23
and the council continues to collect the
parking revenue charges
thank you thank you councillor fd
councillor hoy do you have a
supplementary
thank you
for the answer but also also reading the
card
thank you thank you
do we have someone who would like to
read out the question for council and
mrs carter
councillor mrs mason will
thank you madam chairman i think it's
unfortunate that due to rather
exceptional circumstances this was
originally planned to come to council in
october
which explains partially the
difficulties we're having tonight with
the questions
the question
on notice is as follows this council
notes that the death threat was updated
within rdc in 2018
and including in this was animal welfare
it is understood that there is a backlog
taking up to 10 weeks for applications
within the animal welfare department
issuing licenses and answering general
questions
to residents
it is understood that currently there
are only two officers employed
in the licensing department
will the portfolio holder council cheryl
rowe explain how and when this will be
improved
also
can the fault holy holder advise us if
there is a plan in place to either bring
in extra staff to help reduce this
waiting period in a reasonable time
frame and the plans to continue to
manage this service
efficiently
this council understands that the dog
groomers or walkers aren't required to
have any licenses at all to perform this
service
since it's pandemic more and more people
have undertaken this occupation to
enhance their income
and it has become a popular business
venture with little or no experience at
all and is currently unregulated
can the portfolio holder reassure pet
owners by investigating and reviewing
this current situation and bringing the
controlled messages necessary to ensure
the safety of animals so catered for
finally could the portfolio holder
explain how the style rating system
currently in place works how it is
regulated and what steps will be taken
to improve publicity and understanding
of this system thank you thank you
councillor mrs mason
councillor rowe would you like to
respond please
thank you chairman thank you councillor
mrs mason on behalf of um councillor mrs
carter
as mentioned defra introduced the
relatively new animal licensing act 2018
regulations requiring applicants
to now evidence a considerable amount of
paperwork before issuing a licence and
these new procedures
in addition to the ongoing impact of
managing the covered impact
for all those licensed businesses we
support has meant our normal level of
service
in particular for animal welfare
provision has not been at the level we
would like it to be
following the introduction of the 2018
regulations
an average existing licence holder
renewal application will now take
approximately 20 hours
of officer time before a license is
issued and longer for new applicants
i wanted to take this opportunity to
reassure you that we are continuing to
look at solutions to ensure further
delays are reduced
and this includes working with the city
of london animal welfare team to provide
the licensing team with additional
resources to manage the demand
in relation to the existing licence
holders the team have scope in the
legislation to extend licenses until the
licensing team or a qualified inspection
such as a vet
is able to attend the venue to conduct
the physical inspection
we have extended the licenses for eight
premises until april 2022 to provide
some reassurance to the licence holders
the license holders have been notified
of this extension
no existing businesses have been put at
risk or are able to continue to operate
under existing arrangements
in relation to new applicants the
licensing team did see an increase in
applications with people working from
home and seeking additional income
from looking after other people's
animals
12 applications
in total and the team at this time
use the full 10 weeks allowed under the
regular under the regulations
which helped the service prior
prioritize their service demands and
manage the new process
the team currently have three active new
home border applications
all of these applications have been
initially assessed by the team and are
awaiting the applicants to provide
additional information to them to
demonstrate them the meat
and to meet the con conditions outlined
within the legislation
in relation to the scoring matrix any
new applicant under the regulations will
automatically be considered a high risk
applicant
due to not having at least three years
history in relation to running a
business
this means the maximum score they can
achieve will be either two stars for
meeting all of the standard conditions
or four stars if they have obtained
formal qualifications and their property
meets the highest standard conditions
those who have been licensed for more
than three years can achieve three stars
if they meet the standard conditions and
five stars if they can evidence that
they meet the higher standings which
again include the formal qualifications
if an existing premises is failing to
meet these standard conditions they will
receive a one star license and must be
assessed again within 12 months
the licensing team try to and work with
all existing and new applicants to
ensure they meet the standard conditions
the general public are aware of the
scores and automatically say that anyone
with either two stars or three stars are
not as good with those with four or five
stars
this is not the case it is simply either
that they have not obtained the
additional qualification or their
premises do not allow them to meet the
highest standards
there is currently a review by defra
about the whole process
sorry once this has been completed we
will work with the communications team
to promote the safeguarding steps
the license holders have taken to
protect their people's animals
finally in relation to dog walkers the
dog groomers they do not fall within the
rent remit
of the legislation
the animal welfare regulations are being
reviewed this year
and the very and the view of death ray
has been monitored by the team
thank you chairman
thank you councillor
councillor mrs mason would you like to
supplement your question
thank you
uh thank you councillors for a very
informative and comprehensive response
i'm sure
uh councillor mrs castle will appreciate
that
i'd just like to come back on
one issue
the dog groomers walkers
are the council going to make
representation on that behalf
on that point at all
to jeffrey to the review
thank you
thank you councillor mrs mason
councilman councillor would you like to
respond
thank you chairman um i'm sure our
council will make representation thank
you chairman thank you
moving on to agenda item five business
from last meeting
members
does anyone have any questions related
to the business from the last council
meeting
okay moving on to agenda item six
to note the minutes of the executive and
committee meetings held between the
period 7th of october
2021 to the 23rd of november 2021
are these noted members
thank you
agenda item 8
report on urgent decisions
members there are none
agender item 9 report of the leader on
the work of the executive
is this noted members
thank you
agenda item 10 motions on notice
members there are three motions on
notice which will be taken in order
councillor mrs mason would you like to
introduce your emotional notice
thank you madam chairman you'll forgive
you hear me this on
um
does uh
right most you'll notice that this
council complies and publishes a list
and if possible an interactive map of
all public defibrillators in the
rochford district including those in
non-council premises
that this council reviews and where
appropriate increases the provision and
accessibility of defibrillators across
all council-owned spaces including
public parks community centres leisure
facilities and areas of high public
football
that this council engages with local
organizations to promote the training of
the use of aeds
and training in cpr
but this council promotes the provision
of defibrillators in community buildings
such as day centres across the district
whilst there are some resource
implications to this action the council
acknowledges that such actions will have
the ability to save lives of our
residents
and therefore should become a priority
the signatures to the motion have
provided the following supporting
information
this council notes that on average 30
000 people each year in the uk suffer a
sudden cardiac arrest outside of
hospital and 20 of those incidents occur
in public spaces
this council further notes only 10 of
victims of cardiac arrest survive
when the incident occurs outside of
hospital
automatic external defibrillators
can play a significant role in saving
the lives of people who suffer heart
attacks in public
and it is estimated that a shock from an
aed
alongside cpr treatment increases
survival rates by 75 to 80 percent
many of you will be aware of the role of
first responders
nhs are ambulance trained volunteers who
assist the ambulance service in their
local area
these responders
by dint of being local
often reach the patient before the
ambulance service and provide essential
life support using resuscitation
techniques
including the use of defibrillators
most of you would not be aware that when
the essex emblem service initiated this
scheme 20 years ago in the north of
essex my husband john and i successfully
came out okay this is mason i think
you've
no i'm not i'm ready i'm
speaking to the motion
am i not allowed to do that
i did speak with the ceo and he advised
me i could are you now saying i can't no
please continue
thank you
most of you
will not be aware that when the essex
ambulance service initiated this scheme
20 years ago in the north of essex my
husband john and i successfully
campaigned the similar schemes in our
area and formulated hawkwood heartstart
group to provide equipment
which then cost over hundred two
thousand five hundred and recruit
volunteers for teams in ashington
hawkwell hockley and rochford
what you may also be unaware of is that
one of our own councillors
councillor adrienne was a first
responder
so i'm personally aware that the timely
use of a defibrillator saves lives
with the
difficulty of traveling anywhere in our
district
in a timely fashion due to the
congestion often found in our rows these
life-saving devices have an even more
important role to play
some defibrillator facts for you they
can be used by on a person of any age
and now cost as little as 600 pounds
they can also be rented
you do not need training to be able to
save someone's life with the use of a
defibrillator
the device will begin by analyzing the
victim's heart rhythm and will then
guide the rescuer through each step with
visual and or voice prompts
you cannot shock someone whose heart is
beating
the sooner the heart is put back into
rhythm the better the outcome
nationally there have been repeated
calls for
among other initiatives all schools to
have defibrillators
and each year an average of 270 children
die at school in the uk from sudden
arrhythmic death syndrome
six a week from the echo
let us not wait for national initiatives
but formulate our own
policy to protect the lives of our
children and all our residents
at this present situation locally
once a 999 call is received the
ambulance service will advise
if it is aware of a nearby defibrillator
some premises also have signs outside
without easily accessible public
knowledge of the location of aeds
the value is lost as each minute
diminishes lost so it diminishes the
chance of survival by up to 10 percent
timing and access to accurate
information is critical
this motion aims to build and improve on
the present situation to increase
survival rates in the case of sudden
hospital
heart failure you have used your five
minutes well you interrupted me so allow
me to finish
residents who have had the unfortunate
situation
of experiencing the situation have
commented that even when unsuccessful
such assistant normally provides great
comfort please sit down councillor
missus those who are left behind and if
this council can save one night and
avoid
disastrous ripple effect of sudden death
surely it should do so thank you
reeves would you like to second that
councillor
williams
thank you madam chairman
um members i've spoken to the ambulance
service and first responders at length
regarding these proposals
their opinion is much the same as my own
as well as others there is already a
national database in place called the
circuit
this is the national data
sorry the national defibrillator
defibrillator network supported by the
ambulance service and jobs ambulance etc
where owners that have defibrillators
register the defibrillator with them
on receiving an emergency call the
ambulance service will then assess the
situation and advise the caller on the
best course of action for each
individual case
this may well be where where the nearest
defibrillator is along with its
unlocking code and instructions on how
to use it and if it should be used
it may well be that the that
cpr be the best treatment especially if
a paramedic is only minutes away
to look up the location of a
defibrillator on a database and all go
looking for one may well be detrimental
to the
the patient's well-being i therefore
propose that this motion be refused that
the council signposts responsible owners
refrigerators to register and how to
register their devices with the
ambulance service otherwise the circuit
whenever possible as a member of
rochester parish council who are
responsible for two registered devices
both with the ambulance service as known
as the circuit
it's my understanding that they have now
been used eight times successfully using
this location system
after calling the emergency services
and in contact with the operator and
being instructed on how and when if to
use them
thank you chairman thank you council
williams
yeah can i just remind members that the
normal rules of debate apply and that no
members should speak for longer than
five minutes and should not repeat
anything previously said of all those
indicating to speak will be given an
opportunity to speak once
councillor reeves
thank you chair i'll be brief
as a
former first responder um
information is king and i do understand
that we do have the information
uh available from the ambulance service
but i've got to be honest this is the
first time i've actually heard of where
it actually is and i've been involved
that point uh with this i just think it
might be
good for our community
to be able to point out that we do
actually have these facilities in the
area if it's not too much work
uh to actually include a page on the
website the council's website it might
be appreciated by residences
that's it thank you
thank you councillor eves
councillor smith
thank you chairman
um
i do understand the sentiments of the
emotion that counselor mrs mason has put
forward but i have to agree with council
williams in this case
i think that if you have too many people
all with good intentions trying to
create databases then you'd potentially
risk the chance of information being
diluted or not been readily available
i've researched one defibrillator
database and it tells me of the seven
units in total in rochford district and
two of those are in found s that's just
not good enough we need to use the sir
the the circuit the database that has
become the most prominent and most
commonly used thank you
thank you councillor smith
councillor wilkinson
thank you chairman
i agree in principle with the sentiments
behind the motion but i do have a
question i mean because i um i'm trained
in defibrillators so i do understand the
benefits of it
um
i'm interested actually where the gaps
are
i don't know how many defibrillators
we've got across the district so where
are the gaps that we would need to fill
and how much is that going to cost us um
so i would need to know those sort of
details if that's possible
thank you councillor wilkinson
councilman mcpherson
thank you chairman um
i think most of us in here agree with
the sentiments of the motion
um
i'm not quite sure what happened tonight
so i'm just going to speak on the motion
that we had on notice that i read and
researched on
um i too am a volunteer i think quite a
few people in here are and i'm a
volunteer with the wakering
defibrillator project
so i've got first hand experience of
fundraising buying installing and the
ongoing maintenance of defibrillators
we have installed four then worked with
other partners to place more and i also
know another group are now placing them
further afield in south end
councillor williams is correct when he
mentions
uh the advice he had from the first
responders
you will probably also get the same
response from the ambulance service
in fact we were told sternly not to
create our own map
not to advertise where they are we can
launch and publicize that but they said
if you create a map or if we put their
it in a little brochure
people will be tempted to go and get
that first
and the first thing they should do in
the event of an emergency is ring nine
nine nine
the emergency services because they work
using the circuit
know where these defibrillators are
placed but more importantly they're
still in use because
if one is deployed the emergency service
take it off the circuit list until it is
returned to the unit
at which point the custodian that's the
posh name for the volunteer caretaker of
that defibrillator does the checks that
it's in order and at this point confirms
to the emergency service that is back on
in use
at which point
it is then put back onto the circuit so
you can see where i'm coming from if we
make up our own list
it may not be accurate
the reason that the project sits best
within the community
is due to that role of the custodian
each and every defibrillator must have
regular checks
daily checks that they are showing the
green light check they are talking to us
they do the doors and the locks are okay
and not tampered with also to check use
by dates on such items as the pads
each of the defibrillators we have
placed in the community has their own
custodian
then we have backup volunteers and a
rotor for such things as holidays or
sickness
the volunteers are all locals that can
do this on their daily walk
as opposed to for instance as this
motion says the council monitoring and
traveling around the district
so you can see why it's best placed
within the community and i think i can
speak for my fellow defibrillator
volunteers
that we enjoy volunteering and doing
something for the community
i don't know if councillor williams had
a secondar if not i will second that
however i will also fully support what
council e said about our council having
a page promoting about defibrillators
sign posting them to the pages that the
experts produce
around
first thing
999 and perhaps also we can advertise
and look for the gaps as has been
pointed out by councillor williamson and
work with those communities to share
expertise across our district thank you
chairman thank you councilman mcpherson
councillor wootton
thank you
madam chairman who could possibly
disagree with the sentiments of this
motion um we fully understand and i
think excellent speech from council
mcpherson certainly uh councillor
wilkinson uh identified an issue which i
know councillor steptoe has alluded to
in the past which is what is important
is to find the gaps in our community so
that we can deal with that
my difficulty of course with this motion
as it is currently written
is that it's what it commits this
council to do
and it's that part of it that i have
difficulty if it is a duplication of a
service which already exists
and the
the creating of the data
is is with another organization so it
just doesn't really make too much sense
to me to commit rochford district
council
to gather data that it's not really in a
position and it's really the first
paragraph
that i have a concern with
nothing else but i think others have
made some very sensible suggestions i'd
like to be put in a position where we
can support it
but
i can't
uh
agree to a uh emotion i can't support a
motion which commits a body
rochford district council doing
something which is neither qualified or
dare i say capable of doing because it
puts us in a very difficult position but
i totally support the spirit of it thank
you
thank you councillor woodson councillor
butcher
thank you yes i don't want to report uh
repeat everything that everyone else has
said but i do agree totally with
councillor mcpherson
i'm also involved in a defibrillator
group uh putting them out you know
funding it and i understand all about
the circuit
but the one thing i will say
is you will talk to a little
three-year-old
child
they know what to do in an emergency 999
that is our emergency number the circuit
is on that
that is where the ambulance um
uh comes from please
let's not confuse things with other
other leaflets
999 from that age upwards we know where
to phone
thank you councillor butcher
councillor lawman
thank you chairman um i
have to support what councillor
mcpherson said and what's been said
again because i'm involved with the
radio station as a friend of the station
and one of the things we do is monitor
the station as part of what we do we
found our defibrillator was stolen
greater angular never knew and yet it
was their machine so all we've replaced
it now and it's on the platform but it's
locked away but someone forced it but no
one said i don't know how it was long it
was gone
my point being is listening to all of
this i think the most important thing is
awareness
awareness of the procedure what can be
done and i'd like to see more in that
rather than taking on responsibility
walking around like some watchmen
stamp in his card as he goes around and
i'd like to see a bit more awareness so
that the general public can be their
eyes and ears for us so if there is an
issue with this equipment someone gets
told about it that's my point
thank you thank you councillor lorman
is that everyone
councillor newport
thank you chairman um i've certainly
learned a lot tonight um i hadn't heard
of the circuit to be honest so
that's very informative
one thing i will um
i will
mention is that
there's been a lot of um talk about
duplicating etc
and
there are such things as apis which is a
data feed from
that potentially we could use from
circuit and i think
it is raising awareness
but also
one of the issues that i do have with
defibs are the availability
of them in our
um
in our wards
because the one we have in tesco's
tesco's closes at 11 o'clock at night
so it's not an external um defib and
so i do think that the gaps
in availability do need to be looked at
and
filled where possible thank you
councillor newport
i think we've had a full debate on this
uh councillor mrs mason would you like
to come back on this
i think we need new equipment
um
i think the issue with this and
listening to the concerns is something
that people aren't aware that circuit
and both the ambulance service do not
know where all the defibrillators in the
area are that i certainly know somewhere
that people have put them in and they've
not registered them at all so that was
one of the concerns but the concern the
consensus scenes that we should be
communicating and having a list and i'm
quite happy to amend the motion to put a
page on the website if that is the
general consensus what i do think we
need to do is to communicate and to give
information because it is important that
this is done thank you
thank you councillor mrs mason we will
now take this
the motion that you put forward to the
vote
those in favor
please raise your hands
no it's there is no amendment by
councillor williams
oh
okay
do do you have a second uh councillor mr
mason
okay
councillor so we will now speak to the
amendment those in favor of the
amendment
please raise your hand
mrs mason if you could state your
amendment please
that the council publishes
a list on its website pointing to the
other areas information so the
communication that and information that
is available is also available to all
our residents
oh sorry
um i'm not quite clear now is the
amendment
suggesting that the list that we
discussed
and i think mostly uh disagreed with
now be put on the website
council mrs mason are you able to answer
that
yes certainly
the list and the links to the other
services are put on the website
because if we don't publish anything
we're doing nothing
and
i'm quite happy to amend it to that
point so the council actually publishes
on its website the links to the
ambulance service and circa if it wants
in the circuit but also any other ones
that aren't included on there because
there are ones that they don't know
about
thank you councilman mrs mason
sorry can i just clarify
i feel that from the conversations we've
had today the only thing that we can put
on that website
is signposting people to ring 999 in the
case of emergency and they will then
signpost them on to the appropriate
ambulance service and where the
defibrillators are i don't feel that
that's any more than we've agreed to
tonight
thank you councilman gaddison
uh councillor wilkins wilkinson you've
you have already spoken
are you on the amendment okay thank you
very briefly
thank you chairman um so i can i just
clarify because just something that
counselor mrs mason just said and i want
to understand and i think for the
benefit of all of us um she says she's
amending to that point so am i right in
saying that you're mending the first
paragraph but your intention is the rest
of the motion stands or are you
withdrawing the rest of the motion
i think in the light of the lack of
support tonight i will draw the rest of
the motion thank you
excuse
me counselor sorry
chairman you find me
[Music]
um i just want to uh clarify the motion
put forward by council mrs mason
um
i have on paper that this council
publishes on its website
a list
of all public defibrillators
in the rocha district including those in
non-council premises
that this council reviews are well
appropriate increases the provision and
accessibility of defibrillators across
all council-owned spaces including
public parks community centres
leisure facilities and areas of high
public footfall that this council
engages with local organizations to
prevent the trading of the training of
the use of aeds and cpr training
the rest of the motion has been
withdrawn is that correct mrs mason
well that's not quite what i said but
i said that this
council publish
publishes a list
links on its website and list
um
including those and of of all
defibrillators that it's aware of i've
withdrawn the rest of it because i don't
see that there's any support of it so
i've left it as simple as that thank you
councillor mrs mason
councillor myers
thank you madam chairman
um
the point of this would appear to be
we're going around in circles the only
two things that need to be on the
council website are a dial 999 mb wwe
which will direct people if they do have
a defibrillator to register on the
circuit and it will be done that's the
only two things i think we need to
actually put on there thank you
councillor
myerson mcpherson
thank you chairman i don't think i could
have said that better myself i think
we've just got to have the emergency
information on there i ideally run that
past the emergency service to make sure
they're happy with it
and if people or community groups have a
defibrillator in their community how
they register it
that's it end of thank you councilman
mcpherson
would counsel mrs mason be agreeable to
that
slight amendment to it yes i would
if the officers got that perhaps they
could read that out thank you
councillor mcpherson would you like to
read out what you just said so that we
can take that amendment
if councillor mrs mason is agreeable to
this that we provide emergency
information what our public do in the
event of emergency
and
if people are part of a community
defibrillator project or have a
defibrillator how they register it and
provide the web link to the circuit
and councillor mrs mason is nodding to
indicate that's okay
thank you chairman
those in favor of the
well you're gonna read it out
that
this council
[Music]
that the council provides
emergency information
of what the public should do in the
event of an emergency
and if people are
involved in a community defibrillator
project
or have
have a defibrillator in their community
that they're given the information on
how to register it
plus also put the uh put the link on the
website to the
[Music]
to the circuit i think i think that was
probably at all
councillor ward please
thank you chairman
um i agree with everything that's just
gone on
but i would also like to add on the part
about training
about encouraging organizations to get
involved in training because i think
that's a very important factor it's very
good having the defibrillators out there
but i believe that a lot of the
volunteers who have actually done that
may want to encourage others and
organizations to
look at training thank you
counselor mrs mason are you in agreement
that we add that final sentence which
was also in part of your motion
that the council engages with local
organizations to promote the training of
the use of aeds and cpr training
thank you
councillor eve so you're in agreement
second in that thank you
any more questions
we will take this to the vote now those
in favor
please raise your hands
thank you members please lower your
hands that is unanimous
and that is carried
now members i'm very aware of time
because
we have a few more items to get through
are we prepared to go over 10 o'clock
so so
we will need to take this to the vote so
those who are in favor
of going past 10 o'clock please raise
your hands
those against
members that was five four taking this
past ten o'clock
24 against and no abstentions
therefore
that is carried and we will not have
time to go on to the next
motion
uh i'll conclude the business
of this evening at 21 48.
members please be upstanding
the chairman and the chief executive
[Music]
thank you members and for those of you
before have a good christmas